hello guys welcome back to jaegerists in
today's video we'll be going through the
story of armin arlert from attack on
titan armin originally lived in the
shiganshina district of walmaria after
his parents were executed for attempting
to escape the walls he was left to live
with his grandfather one day after the
latest in a series of beatings by
bullies armin sat against the building
crying another boy aaron yeager appeared
around the corner with a shady look on
his face aaron asked armin why he never
fought back and claimed that that was
why they treated him like that he then
asked him if he wanted to be on the
losing side forever armand then claimed
that he was not losing by not running
away aaron then asked for his name and
the two began a friendship one day arma
discovered a book belonging to his
grandfather describing the outside world
inspired by what he read he showed the
book to aaron who was subsequently
inspired by armin's excitement to leave
the walls one day reading from his
grandfather's book about salty oceans
deserts and other surreal or unheard of
places armin expressed a desire to one
day venture out and see these
magnificent sites for himself in the
year 845 armin would once again find
himself cornered by bullies who mocked
him for his deep curiosity for the
outside world refusing to fight back
armin would later need to be rescued by
the timely appearance of aaron and
mikasa later he and his two friends
settle by the riverbank where aaron
broods over his desire to join the
survey corps just as armin muses how the
walls cannot protect humanity forever
the colossus titan appears and
subsequently breaches wal-maria as armin
and the others watch in horror as titans
flood the shiganshina district aaron and
mikasa head back home to find their
doomed mother armin tries to stop them
but finds himself petrified by fear
unbeknownst to aaron and mikasa armin
was the one to locate and inform hannes
to save the two before they get killed
by the titans with no family left armin
moved into a settlement with aaron until
the two of them turned 12 and were able
to join the military armin decides to
enlist into military training along with
mikasa and aaron he was able to pass the
basic aptitude test after some effort
and tried to help aaron with it when he
struggled to stay upright although high
in intellect armin was considered weak
in physical strength and did not
graduate at the top of the class the
night after their graduation and before
the trainees had decided on their chosen
section of the military armin sits with
aaron and mikasa to eat and watches as
aaron responds to a taunting jean by
finally deciding to set the record
straight and giving a moving speech to
the whole of the 104th training on how
he wants to kill the titans to gain
freedom and pursue his dream to see the
outside world after dinner armin finds
aaron and mikasa sitting outside the
building and joins them saying that the
party is over and that they should head
back to the barracks before they do
aaron asks armin which section of the
military he'll be joining armin sits
down and reveals that he will join the
survey corps along with aaron and mikasa
aaron questions his choice incredulously
citing armin's physical weaknesses armin
affirms his worries by acknowledging
that he is physically weak aaron
responds supportively but advises armin
not to follow his own crazy course of
action while neglecting his own strong
points armin responds bitterly saying
that he would rather die than become a
burden armin is shaken by the news of
the titan attack on trust he trembles in
fear realizing how sorely unprepared
they are to respond but aaron manages to
shake him out of it later armin joins
aaron's squad in the middle guard of
trust and exchanges confident words with
aaron about killing titans and soon
after departs with mina carolina thomas
wagner melia zaramouski and naktias to
their assigned location along the way
thomas is caught by surprise and eaten
by an abnormal titan enraged in vengeful
aaron charges ahead of the others to
engage the titan while armin and the
others follow suit however the group is
ambushed and torn apart by the
surrounding titans leaving only armin
and aaron alive with aaron missing his
left leg shocked and horrified armin is
left immobile as a nearby titan plucks
him up and attempts to swallow him aaron
just barely conscious enough to remember
how armand inspired him to see the
outside world leaps to armin's aid aaron
hurls armin out of the titan's mouth but
is eaten in his place as armin screams
in anguish stuck in a state of shock for
some time armin is shaken out of it by
connie who questions where the rest of
his squad is armin suffers a mental
breakdown despising himself for his
cowardice that resulted in aaron's death
he leaves to inform the rear guard of
what happened while lamenting how the
world is and always has been hell on the
way he encounters hannah trying to
resuscitate france armin tells hannah to
stop seeing all too well that france is
bisected and already dead armin is later
confronted by mikasa above the rooftops
with the other stranded trainees she
questions him about aaron's location but
as soon as armin looks at her with
tearful eyes she understands armin
blurts out the names of all the fallen
soldiers in erin's squad ending with
aaron himself despite his clear regret
mikasa calmly comforts armin and
explains that they must not get
emotional at a time like this armin
follows as mikasa guides the leaderless
trainees to safety but realizes how she
is only masking her distress when mikasa
carelessly uses up all of her gas armin
comes to her aid soon after armin along
with nikasa and connie witness the
appearance of the mysterious titan who
only kills other titans when mika says
gas is exhausted armin provides her with
all the remaining fuel and blades that
he has seemingly ready to remain behind
armin requests to keep one blade
implying to commit suicide with it but
mika sankani refused to leave him behind
with trust's military headquarters
overrun with titans and the remaining
soldiers running low on fuel armin
devises a plan to lure the mysterious
titan towards the hq to wipe out the
surrounding titans once inside the hq
armor constructs a plan to eliminate the
titans infesting the supply depot inside
while armin and several other soldiers
act as bait members of the 104th top 10
would slay the seven titans by jumping
on them from the rafters armin's
strategy works and the trainees kill all
the titans and refuel their equipment
shortly after armin witnesses aaron
miraculously emerged from the mysterious
titans nape unconscious but alive after
being recovered aaron is detained by a
group of soldiers who are going to
execute him armin amika said defend him
as he wakes up surprised and confused
aaron plans to escape over the walls
unless armin is able to convince the
soldiers of aaron's value to humanity
aaron tells him that his quick thinking
has saved him and mikasa before as he
was the one who went to hannes when
shiganchina was overrun armin more
confident than ever walks into the open
and tries to convince the soldiers of
aaron's value in humanity's battle
against the titans citing the many
titans aaron killed in his titan form as
a soldier he then passionately declares
that he is ready to die for this cause
and makes a grand salute pixis noticing
his determination and passion prevents
their execution now with a boost of
self-confidence he tells the senior
strategists that aaron could carry the
boulder over to the hole while other
soldiers could lure the titans towards
the walls they proceed with the plan
later when aaron loses control of his
titan form and knocks himself out armin
rushes to aaron and lands on his back
remembering the spot where aaron had
risen earlier armin stabs him a little
askew so that it would not be fatal but
would wake him up he reminds aaron of
his personal vendetta against the titan
but aaron only becomes responsive once
he reminds him of the world beyond the
wall and asks him to think of the reason
he wanted to go out there to begin with
aaron successfully motivated by armin's
words carries the boulder and plugs the
breach the newly returned survey corps
helped mop up the remaining titans in
trost armin is then present as a witness
to the hearing that decides aaron's fate
as a now revealed titan the trial ends
with aaron being placed in the custody
of the survey course captain levi he and
mikasa are then separated from aaron
until they're able to join the survey
corps before the trainees are able to
decide their chosen military paths the
news spreads that two captured titans
sunny and bean were slain and armin
along with other trainees from the 104th
training squad are called in for
inspection armin annie and connie
discuss which branch of the military
they would join to the surprise of
connie armin declares he intends to join
the survey corps and he compliments
armin on his courage but states she
still wants to join the military police
and survive to any surprise armin tells
her that she is also a good person
because he can tell she does not want
them to join the survey corps either she
disagrees saying that she is not a good
person because she just wants to assure
her own survival by joining the military
police after joining the survey corps
with erin and mikasa and the rest of the
104th top 10 armin participates in the
survey corps 57 expedition venturing
beyond wall rose not long into the
expedition arm and squad encounters the
female titan which is seemingly highly
intelligent and has considerable
knowledge about the military's formation
the female titan kills armin's entire
squad but spares armin's life after
carefully removing his hood and
observing his face
as the female titan moves on greiner and
jean meet up with armin and the three
pursued the mysterious titan armin
suggests the female titan like aaron is
a human control type and is likely
hunting for aaron the three attempt to
engage the female titan and armin is
thrown off his horse but yet again the
female titan does not kill him the three
managed to distract her for a while
though she immediately makes a b-line
for aaron's position after warding
armin's group off though they survived
the encounter armin john and reiner are
left stranded with only one horse which
is only strong enough to carry two at a
time while reiner is patching armin up
he thinks about the female titan sparing
him a second time after being bandaged
up by reiner armin offers to stay behind
but luckily krista quickly arrives with
two spare horses in tow reaching the
titan forest armin and his fellow
soldiers perch on its many high branches
distracting titans while erwin confronts
the female titan while they wait armin
concludes that irwin withheld vital
information from most of the soldiers
out of fear of traitors lurking among
them jean criticizes his commander's
action but armand defends irwin stating
that playing it safe will not bring
about change when the expedition
ultimately ends in failure armin safely
returns to wall rose with the remainder
of the survey corps before the operation
of stoaz irwin levi and other survivors
from the 57th expedition hold a meeting
in the old survey corps headquarters to
confirm the identity of the female titan
army shares his theory that the female
titan is annie sometime later in stowe's
district armin locates and asks annie
now a military police member for her
help in hiding aaron when they need to
flee walsheena to avoid aaron's
inevitable execution although initially
hesitant annie accepts and armin
explains that they must smuggle aaron
out of waushina by foot taking an
underground route as he aaron and mikasa
enter the underground tunnel annie
refuses to follow realizing that armin
has led her into a trap armin confronts
annie asking her why she was in
possession of marco bot's vertical
equipment during equipment inspection
annie claims that she simply found it
but then admits to have killed the two
captured titans using her own equipment
when armin accuses her of such annie
questions why armin did not take action
if he was already so suspicious of her
but armin states he simply could not
believe it and questions why annie chose
not to kill him when she had the chance
annie is not sure herself but
congratulates armin on managing to
corner her confirming her identity as
the female titan armin fires a sound
grenade signaling hidden soldiers to
restrain annie despite their efforts
annie succeeds in injuring herself using
a barb hidden in her father's ring
allowing her to transform anticipating
this mikasa grabs both aaron and armin
and takes them further underground as
annie in her titan form attempts to grab
them seeing that his strategy has failed
armin initiates plan b trying to
encourage aaron to fight annie aaron
tries repeatedly to assume his titan
form but can't do so due to his
reluctance to fight a friend having no
other option armin suggests he and
mikasa distract annie so that aaron may
safely flee realizing that if he doesn't
fight that his friends will surely die
aaron finally transforms into a titan
and fights annie after realizing that
she is fighting a losing battle with
aaron and the survey corps annie decides
to make her escape by climbing over the
wall mikasa cuts off the female titans
fingers and aaron pins her to the ground
allowing the other survey corps members
to extract annie from the nape of her
titan when aaron emerges from his titan
form and asks about annie's fate armin
informs him that no one knows he shows
him that annie encased herself in rock
hard crystal upon being pulled out of
her titan as aaron rehabilitates armin
takes a moment to rest with the others
armin and former jean that aaron summons
to the king were cancelled and an annie
is indeed the female titan she's being
detained underground after encasing
herself in a crystal to avoid
interrogation reflecting on the
mysterious titans found in the walls
armin observes that for all these years
they were being protected from the
titans by titans armin could not fathom
how the walls were built in the first
place but hypothesizes that abilities
like annie's hardening power were
somehow employed armin's hypothesis is
later confirmed when the rock sample
that squad leader hanji zoid had picked
up from annie's titan body matched the
properties of the walls with this
information in mind armin and hanji
propose a way to repair walmaria aaron
to use his own hardening ability to mend
that breach minister nick informs the
group about a girl in the survey court
who may know more about the walls
stating that while he cannot share any
of the details she can armin and the
others immediately recognize the girl in
question to be crystal lens rescuing
krista reiner berthold connie and a
grievously injured emir from utgard
castle armin and the survey corps
regroup on top of wall rose however
armin shortly after learns of reiner and
bertolt's secret correspondence with
annie confirming his and hanji's
suspicion that the two are also spies as
reiner and bertolt attempt to take
possession of aaron they are attacked
and nearly killed by mikasa but survive
a horrified armin is present to witness
reiner and bertolt's titan
transformation marking the second and
third appearance of the armored and
colossus titans respectively armin is
called by hanji to aid aaron as he
battles reiner in his titan form
meanwhile the colossus titan is kept
busy defending himself from the rest of
the core advising aaron to retreat to
the wall armin provides mikasa with his
spare blades to support aaron against
the armored titan armin and hanji put
their heads together and realized that
in order to move the area behind the
armored titan's knees must be
unprotected they then advised mikasa to
[ __ ] the armored titan's knees
allowing aaron to gain the upper hand
however just as the battle turns in
aaron's favor the armored titan lets out
a loud whale signalling bertolt who then
proceeds to push himself off of wall
rolls and crash down on aaron and reiner
below reiner and bertolt succeed in
kidnapping aaron and yamir in the chaos
and armin informs mikasa after she
regains consciousness that five hours
have already passed since then mikasa
despairs at the news but her and armin's
determination are revived upon hearing a
rousing speech from hanes joining a
force comprised of survey corps
reinforcements garrison and military
police soldiers all led by erwin armin
and the others begin pursuing aaron and
his kidnappers as armin and the others
reached the titan force where reiner and
bertolt were resting they are beset by
titans entering the force with their
vertical equipment armin's team
encounters emir in her titan form arma
notices ymir suspiciously surveying
everyone and neglecting to attack anyone
his suspicions were confirmed when yamir
suddenly captures krista and escapes
realizing that she has sided with the
traitors reiner transforms into his
titan form and flees the force with
bertolt ymir and a restrained aaron in
tow pursuing on horseback armin notes
that while the armor titan is slow
stopping him will be difficult due to
reiner not shedding his joint armor
eventually armin and his fellow trainees
succeed in latching onto the armored
titan where they implore bertolt to
surrender aaron just as bertolt suffers
a breakdown armin and the others are
forced to briefly retreat when erwin
charges into the fray followed by a
horde of titans the mass of titans
behind irwin attacked the armored titan
slowing him down to a crawl and irwin
leads his forces into the chaos seizing
the opportunity to rescue aaron
unfortunately irwin is bitten and
carried off by a titan along the way but
armin remains focused on the mission and
joins the second attempt to retrieve
aaron using his equipment to climb onto
the armored titan's head armin confronts
bertholdt purposefully taunting him with
lies that annie is being tortured while
he and reiner save themselves enraged
bertolt charges at armond but is
intercepted by a grievously wounded
irwin who slashes aaron off of him with
aaron secured irwin's forces retreat but
their escape is cut off by reiner who
tosses titans in their way armin is
horrified by the risk that reiner is
taking seeing that aaron could easily be
eaten in a struggle aaron and mikasa are
knocked from their horse and jean is
incapacitated as he and others rush to
assist them with nowhere to run armin
drags jean towards a small cluster of
trees and prepares to face an advancing
titan with only one sword he looks to
aaron and mikasa seeing them in just as
desperate a situation however armin is
saved when aaron's coordinate power
suddenly activates causing the titans to
attack first the smiling titan and then
the armored titan this allows armin to
retrieve a horse and carry a wounded
jean to safety they retreat from the
battlefield mourning the loss of hanes
who died in the chaos and remembering
their childhood with him returning
safely to wall rose aaron greemley
remarks that he got captured again and
asks how many people got injured because
of him armin tries to soften the
situation saying that they experienced
no losses on the way back with the
titans ignoring them and only attacking
the armored titan he mentions the female
titan being able to draw other titans
toward itself and states his and jean's
theory that aaron had controlled the
titans this time some time later armin
is seen helping jean and sasha carry
food into their new relocated house
aaron appears and reminds them all of
the importance of cleaning off their
shoes before coming in causing jean to
yell at him and remind him that he is
not his mother mikasa and historia come
back after chopping wood much to arm in
shock as he tries to remind her that she
is not a wild animal and should not be
moving around yet as the group banter
and argue sasha speaks on how this is
like all of them being trainees again
armin is quick to remind everyone that
protecting aaron and historia is an
important task he then asks why they
were selected for levi's new squad aaron
tells them all to finish cleaning before
levi and connie return the group then
reunites with levi and discuss armin's
idea of sealing the hole in walmaria
using aaron's titan hardening abilities
hanji informs them that nick was found
dead that morning tortured and murdered
by members of the military police's
first interior squad and armin wonders
how much he would have revealed though
levi guesses he did not reveal anything
he also was there when historia told
about her path prior to her enlistment
in the survey corps during a failed test
for aaron to harden his titan form armin
was present he was also present when the
group read irwin's orders looking
shocked at the sight of it during their
first official operation armin served as
a body double for historio and is
eventually captured by the organization
that wishes to take possession of aaron
and historia while being held captive
with jean who was serving as aaron's
double one of the men harasses him
asking over and over to hear armin's
voice as he was suspected to be historia
armin displayed great discomfort at this
being driven to tears from it armin is
seen still tied up with jean as the men
issued to take aaron and krista arrive
observing them silently before they are
attacked by mikasa and levi he and jean
then raced from their positions
revealing that they were pretending to
be tied up and tied the beaten men up as
aaron and historia are kidnapped by the
first interior squad he's seen at trust
district preparing with the rest of the
survey corps to retrieve the caskets in
which erin and historia are being
transported one female member of the
first interior squad gets through and
tries to shoot armand but mikasa kicks
her and she lands on the carriage she
gets up ignores jon's threat and knocks
his gun away while she is pointing a gun
at jean armin reacts quickly pulls out
his own gun and shoots her in the head
thus he helps save jean after the survey
corps retreat to safety he was not able
to take the guilt of killing another
human being and becomes sick mikasa
comforts him levi tells him that he
cannot go back to being the way he was
as his hands are now already dirty after
the survey core is accused of trying to
monopolize aaron's titan powers the
government begins arresting all members
of the organization
armin and the rest of the squad levi
avoid being captured and camp out in the
woods outside of stoaz the squad
ambushes two mps with armin distracting
them as bait mikasa and armin take their
uniforms and put them on with the
intention of infiltrating the military
police to find out where aaron and
historia have been taken but the two
soldiers marlow and hitch do not take
their capture quietly and eventually
gain the squad's trust leading them to a
nearby mp checkpoint
after crippling most of the personnel
levi and his squad escape with a hostage
and interrogate him about aaron and
historia's location they hear people
approaching on foot and prepare for
battle to the entire squad's delight it
is hanji who informs them that the
survey corps has been exonerated and
that they have a lead on aaron and
historia's whereabouts as the group
begins to ride for the reese chapel
armin silently wonders who aaron had
inherited his titan from armin plays a
pivotal role in planning out their fight
with the remaining interior mp forces
stationed at the chapel the plan is to
take cover under the smoke by igniting
gunpowder inside barrels and also by
utilizing their smoke signals as it
would be advantageous for them with
their low numbers hanji is injured
during the fighting and armin is left
behind to take care of her armin and
hanji meet up with levi's squad after
they escape the cavern and follow rod's
titan as it makes its way to orvo
district meeting up with irwin's forces
in route at dawn the titan arrives and
aaron mikasa and armin assemble a stack
of barrels filled with gunpowder at
hanji's direction aaron sees a group of
kids below and remarks on how they
remind him of himself and his friends on
that day when the colossus titan first
appeared armin agrees but reminds aaron
that there's a difference this time with
them being ready to face the threat to
arm in surprise aaron suddenly begins
punching himself to bring himself back
to his senses after historia has been
crowned queen he is seen helping out at
the farm for the orphans and people in
need from the underground he and the
rest of survey corps prepare for the
upcoming mission for retaking wall maria
and have meals together before they set
out for the mission he reminisces their
childhood with aaron amikaza and
enthusiastically talks of being able to
see the outside world stating that they
should start by visiting the ocean
during the journey towards shiganshina
he notices aaron seemingly in fear and
doubt and encourages him reminding him
of their collective dream to see the
outside world making him feel better
after arriving in shiganshina armin and
his squad take up positions atop
walmaria as the rest of his squad
proceeds to the breach in the wall arma
notices the remains of a campfire nearby
and alerts irwin on erwin's orders armin
proceeds to the foot of the wall where
he finds evidence that three people have
been camping out atop the wall he
returns to irwin to inform him of what
he's found and the two of them deduce
that there's likely a fourth person
accompanying their enemies who warned
them of the core's approach so that they
could hide to arm in surprise irwin
gives him command of a team of soldiers
and orders him to find where their
enemies are hiding as he is searching
armin recalls the fact that the walls
are filled with titans and deduces that
there might be hollow spots where the
warriors could be hiding he orders his
team to search the wall for hollow areas
and despite their initial skepticism
irwin orders them to obey one soldier
stumbles across a hollow spot and from
within emerges reiner who immediately
kills him he prepares to attack armin
but levi swoops down and intervenes
armin is once again entrusted by irwin
to help direct the battlefront where
they would fight the armored titan he
relays irwin's plan to take on the armor
titan to squad leader hanji after they
blow reiner's head off he laments that
with their abilities they could not
afford any negotiations however
grinder's titan form gives out a roar
and armin immediately realizes that it
might be a signal to call bertolt sure
enough he sees a barrel hurling towards
them from the sky thrown by the beast
titan with the colossus titan coming
from above armin and the soldiers try to
flee from the scene but turns around
when he realizes bertolt had not
transformed yet instead of attacking
bertolt armin reminds everyone that they
should make a last attempt to negotiate
with him bertolt shares a bitter
conversation with armin claiming that it
was he who decided to come up with
malicious schemes in order to conquer
humanity thinking fast armin throws
annie's name in the conversation
declaring that only bertolt is capable
of saving her from the military police
bertolt coltley dismisses armin's
remarks and approaches him with his
blade ready he reveals to armin that he
saw through his plan long ago but he
just wanted to ensure he is to kill them
properly a confused armin asks why
bertolt thinks that all humans are
descendants of evil boberto shrugs the
question off and continues to advance
towards him before he can reach armin
however mikasa attacks bertolt from
behind forcing him to defend himself and
then making a quick escape to find
reiner armin attempts to chase after
bertolt but mikasa stops him warning of
bertolt's intentions to transform sure
enough armin soon feels an immense
explosion resonating throughout the
district signifying that bertolt has
taken his titan form armin witnesses the
colossus titan destroy the district when
jean asks armin for a plan armin advises
to tire out the colossus titan because
it cannot climb over the wall jean
interrupts armin's plan deeming it too
dangerous to risk leading the colossus
titan to the wall due to irwin's group
being on the other side jean concludes
that a tactical approach is the logical
plan however they have limited supplies
such as their vertical equipment armin
realizes that this is their only chance
of attack solely counting on their
current manpower jean asks armin for the
next phase of his plan but armin is out
of ideas and requests jon to take over
following jean's order to reach the
river armin climbs onto aaron who stays
out of sight from the colossus titan
jean tells armin that he might be able
to get a grasp of their situation
however in the end he would have to rely
on armin's planning for it to work armin
incredibly frantic is reprimanded by
jean to stop he is tasked to observe the
colossus titan from further back while
aaron attacks him to keep him from
reaching the wall armin looks on in
horror as aaron is kicked to the top of
the wall by the colossus titan as mikasa
retreats from a burst of steam from the
colossus titan armand notices that
mikasa is hurt she asks him if he has
come up with any other ideas but he has
not before they can come up with any
other plans armin looks on in shock to
find the armored titan still alive and
ready to battle once more after some
consideration armin finally comes up
with a plan he explains to the group
that the colossus titan has become
thinner compared to when it first
transformed meaning that it will soon
run out of energy armin tells jean and
mikasa to go after the armored titan
while he and aaron will take on the
colossus reminiscing the days when he
and aaron promised each other that they
would one day see the ocean arming
comments that if this plan fails he will
never get to see it armin then stabs
aaron's titan form telling him to wake
up armin succeeds in waking aaron and
explains the plan to him telling him to
go through with the plan no matter what
aaron hesitantly agrees in accordance
with armin's plan aaron lets his
titanfall fall to the ground in front of
the north gate seemingly defeated armin
stays on the wall pretending to be
surprised as aaron's titan form falls he
secretly hardens his body and escapes
through the nape fleeing from the scene
armin stays to face the colossus titan
grappling to the colossus titan's teeth
armin succeeds in getting bertholdt to
emit a massive wave of heat and smoke
armin remains grappled as the heat
begins to hinder his breathing but he
remains resolute in his decision bertolt
begins to pity arm and selflessness and
emits a massive wave of searing heat and
steam to kill armin quickly as armin's
flesh skin and clothing begins to burn
off armin chooses to remain grappled
realizing that he is about to die and
that aaron must see the ocean in his
stead soon armin's grip on his sword
hilt is broken sending his charred body
flying to the rooftops below as berthold
inspects aaron's heart in titanform
aaron uses his maneuver gear to get
behind berthold slicing him out of the
colossus titan's nape as aaron stands on
the roof by armin's body he sorrowfully
says that armin was always the bravest
of his comrades
as aaron mourns armin's sacrifice sadly
looking down upon his body aaron hears
armin breathing faintly and urges levi
to use the titan injection on armin levi
agrees at first but then reconsiders
when he discovers that irwin is still
alive after a tense altercation with
mikasa and aaron levi remembering
irwin's final moments decides to use the
serum to save armin and transform him
into a pure titan armin's titan form
eats bertolt who had been left behind on
the rooftop for that purpose after
eating berthold armin emerges in his
human form unconscious and fully healed
having acquired the power of the
colossus titan while unconscious armin
has a nightmare about bertolt when he
comes to atop the wall he notices sasha
lying next to him and notices her severe
injuries he sees aaron heading toward
him and he hugs armin when he reaches
him relieved that he's awake
having lost his memories of the events
immediately before his transformation
armin is confused so aaron informs him
on the recent events that happened after
hearing this armin acknowledges that he
ate berthold he feels sick and asks his
comrades why they did not save irwin
instead of him levi states that armin
should not let others regret their
decision on choosing to save him
including himself hanji claims that
armin and herself will have to prepare
for whatever comes next and that they
are in similar situations hanji then
says that she levi erin and mikasa will
be heading out while armin and the rest
of the soldiers remain atop the wall
resting and keeping watch
while aaron and migusa are imprisoned
for having violated military law armin
stays with them on one occasion when
aaron wakes up screaming and confused
armin reminds him why he was in jail
he's confused by aaron's choice of
language at this time for the rest of
their time in jail armin helps aaron
validate the three books discovered in
the jaeger family basement by comparing
them with aaron's memories
here armen recognizes that his lifespan
like all previous holders of a titan
power has been shortened due to the
curse of emir after visiting historia
and trust armin attends a meeting along
with the rest of the survey corps to
discuss how the wall people should
progress following shiganshina he stays
silent seemingly until the end of the
meeting when it is decided to make the
basement's discoveries public knowledge
later on armin joins the survey corps to
be honored for their bravery and success
in the battle of shiganshina district
before the meeting begins armin brings
up the matter of the titan injection
with flock flock candidly states that
irwin was the better choice for the
serum than that all other people reading
the report agreed after a short argument
between flock and the 104th survey corps
members defending armin the group is
called into the hall to begin the
ceremony
armin receives a medal along with the
rest of the survey corps
one year after the battle of tross
district the survey corps embarks on a
scouting mission beyond the wall after a
long journey on horseback armin fulfills
his dream when the survey corps reached
the ocean down at the beachfront armin
seems joyful at having accomplished his
dream yet when attempting to speak about
the ocean with aaron he is only reminded
of the threat lurking on the other side
of the ocean one year after retaking the
territory within wal maria the military
of parody discover a marlin survey ship
near the island armin goes with the
survey corps to intercept the forces and
witnesses aaron's titan up and the ship
and forcing it on the shoreline after
two spies yelena and onyakupon rebel and
shoot the captain of the ship armin
watches from afar the two meeting with
hanji and levi he notes that it is
fortunate that they get the chance to
learn more about the people of marley
but is put off by aaron saying parody
needs to strike hard at marley over the
next three years armin works with aaron
to destroy more than 30 additional ships
sent to parody by marley during that
time armin notes that people from both
parody and marley are learning more
about each other and that the citizens
are just like them not all the people of
marley were enemies and are open to
working together for a better future
armin takes part in a meeting where on
yakapun describes that he is from a
different country and race than the
eldians armin asks him who made them all
and is told the same one who made the
people of marley the subjects of ymir
and who granted the power to ymir
himself a god while at a shooting range
with aaron and mikasa armin is proud to
see both sides cooperating and
interacting with one another he notes
that the port at the harbor will be done
soon and believes that eldians and
marlians will soon be able to fully
cooperate and work together without any
tensions on either side aaron then asks
if he could see anything from bertolt's
memories and armin says nothing that
could help them he looks to aaron and
asks if they should go along with the
elena's plan but aaron cuts him off and
claims that the world still sees them as
monsters feeling that it would be
pointless armin reasons that they merely
need time and aaron again insists that
parody must make the first strike
against marley to buy them the needed
time in 853 armin and the rest of the
104th help construct railroads and
parody while aboard a train armin
overhears the others discuss who should
inherit aaron's titan abilities after
his tenure expires in five years he
silently reflects on how aaron valued
each one of his friends and that due to
wanting them all to live for a long time
he would not accept any of them as a
successor armin is one of several survey
corpsmen who journeyed to marley's
mainland to meet with kiyomi during
their meeting armin is distressed to
hear that it will be exceedingly
difficult for the azumabitos to convince
the world's powers to begin accepting
aldians once again noting that the only
other option would be to take advantage
of historia aaron leaves in the middle
of the meeting and armin and the rest of
the 104th graduates go to look for him
they find aaron and mikasa speaking with
a family living near the azumobitu
estate and agreed to eat dinner with the
family spending the night drinking and
carousing the soldiers sitting on
appearing between politicians to discuss
ld and mistreatment they are horrified
when the speakers begin calling for the
hatred being shown towards eldians to be
redirected toward the aldians living on
parody as they are listening they failed
to notice aaron quietly depart from the
meeting eventually the survey corps
received a letter from aaron informing
them that he will be launching an attack
on marley against their orders and
coordinate a rescue armin is tasked to
infiltrate the marley harbor near the
internment zone at liberio at the time
of the survey corps attack armin sits in
a fishing boat within the harbor as the
marlin armada approaches when navy
soldiers call out to him stating that it
is dangerous armin removes his cloaks
hood and stares tellingly at them before
unleashing an explosive energy burst
inland causing massive damage
transforming into the colossus titan
this explosion destroys the battleships
coming to liberia's reinforcement in his
colossus titan form armin looks down at
the destruction that he has caused
noting sadly that bertolt likely
witnessed the same scene when he
attacked shiganshina district he then
exits from his titan form and uses his
vertical maneuvering equipment to make
his way onto an airship that has been
occupied by the survey corps forces he
discusses with hanji about entering
liberio by using the low-level airspace
moving alongside the lights placed
earlier by the survey corps in order to
collect their troops a very dangerous
mission as everyone has only one chance
to board the ship and the ship can also
be shot down hanji questions whether
armin is possessed by irwin's ghost to
come up with such a risky idea but armin
replies that he wishes this was the case
if that could give them strength but at
the moment if they are unable to
retrieve everyone and aaron they will
have no future armin helps aaron onto
the airship and subsequently stops
mikasa from responding after levi kicks
aaron and has him detained the group
goes to another room in the airship
where they hear an uproar through the
door shortly after jean then comes
through the door with two restrained
children explaining that they had
boarded the airship and one had shot
sasha who was unlikely to survive her
injury arm and mikasa rush out of the
room to see her but sasha dies shortly
afterwards prompting the two to break
down in tears
later he meets with mikasa jean and
connie and reflects on how the
anti-marlin volunteers were arrested
even though they helped give parody aid
despite agreeing with jon's disbelief
armin reflects that it was already
decided while they were in marley he
listens to connie and jean accuse aaron
of sending them to fight despite
supposedly valuing their friendship and
is stunned to hear connie's remark that
aaron laughed after hearing sasha died
instead of expressing sorrow or anger
armin recalls how aaron will be in
control of the founding titan during the
rumbling and resolves to arrange for
them to talk with aaron to determine
which side he is on accepting that they
must be prepared to kill aaron if he
switches sides armin proposes a worst
case scenario to have someone
transformed into a titan and obtain
aaron's powers before the end of his
tenure mikasa protested this but army
repeats that they have to discuss with
aaron and determine first if he is still
on their side armin later attends the
questioning of a group of four survey
corps members who had spread the word
that aaron had been imprisoned after the
raid on liberio afterwards armin goes
back to the holding area underground
where annie's crystal is located he goes
over and touches it to try and access
any information they can use suddenly he
hears hitch behind him telling him not
to touch annie's crystal arm and
stammers that titan memories can be
transferred via touch and was merely
trying to see if he could see anything
he pleads with hitch not to ban him from
visiting annie they walk back outside
and hitch hands armin a newspaper
reporting that people are distrusting
the survey court even more than usual
armin agrees but insists they must hurry
and figure out aaron's true motives
before it's too late
pitch goes off to help several other
members to keep the protesters away
while armin goes with mikasa to a
meeting scheduled with dary exactly he
is shocked to hear darius refuse their
request to see aaron at this time when
armin asks why both of them are stunned
when darius reveals to them the belief
that aaron may be under the control of
zeke armin insists they can be useful in
figuring out aaron's motives but zackly
still does not allow it and dismisses
them moments after leaving an explosion
occurs and mikasa grabs armin and
protects him from the blast arm and
mikasa are horrified to see both the
mangled corpse of darius blown apart
from a bomb planted in his office and
the crowd of protesters seemingly in
support of the act
during a meeting going over the attack
armin recalls seeing zachary's chair in
his office and that darius mentioned a
group of recruits had brought it to his
office having seen a group of survey
corps recruits leave as they arrived at
headquarters armin pieces the two
together just as word reaches to them
that aaron has escaped confinement at a
loss for words armin goes with mikasa
hanji and onyankapun to figure out their
next course of action armin attends
another meeting to discuss how the
military will deal with the jaegerists
pixis instructs the military to secure
historia and zeke and tells armin that
his defenses with the power of the
titans must be stronger than ever
recognizing pixis as the acting
commander commander-in-chief armin asks
him if he has any long-term plans he is
then surprised by the commander's reply
that they should surrender to aaron and
begin negotiations after the meeting's
conclusion armin leaves with the survey
corps veterans to visit a suspicious
restaurant employing niccolo after
arriving at the restaurant to question
niccolo armin and the others wait in the
back room for him to finish cooking a
short while later armin opens the door
to the dining hall after hearing a
commotion and sees nikolo attacking the
runaway warrior candidates he quickly
calls the others into the main room but
is kept at bay due to nikola threatening
one of the candidates
eventually when mr blaus calms the
situation down armin and mikasa bring
the warrior candidate who had killed
sasha into the back room allowing the
blast family to weep as armin talks with
gabby he remarks that her mentality is
very similar to how aaron used to act
just then aaron arrives unexpectedly and
shocks both mikasa and armin armin tries
to speak with aaron but notices his palm
is cut and bleeding seeing aaron's
intent forces both mikasa and armin to
comply with aaron's demands they sit
down at the table with gabby and armin
asks aaron if flock and the other
jaegerists are there to harm the others
aaron merely says they are simply being
moved to another location armin asks
aaron if zeke and yelena have swayed him
to their cause and what drove him to
attack marley on his own aaron merely
responds that he is free at last to do
whatever he pleases and questions if
armin is still visiting annie greatly
shocking armin aaron tells armin that if
memories truly play a part in forming
who a person is that means bertolt's
memories have become part of armin he
calls armin a soft and useless pawn of
the military as aaron reveals mikasa's
heritage has been the sole reason she
has stayed by his side arma notices that
mikasa is visibly suffering from this
and orders aaron to stop after airing
calls make us a mindless slave armin
goes to attack him only to be blocked by
mikasa this stuns and horrifies both of
them armin is still able to punch aaron
who takes the blow and throws him
against the shelf aaron mocks armin's
fighting abilities and effortlessly
beats him as aaron orders his followers
to take them away armin bitterly asks if
aaron wanted the freedom to hurt mikasa
and calls zeke a piece of [ __ ] while
claiming aaron is the true slave this
angers aaron and has them all taken to
shiganshina district sometime later
connie asks armin to use his colossus
titan to escape but the notion is
rejected due to the titan's destructive
power jean would then pry into the
details of armin and mika's encounter
with aaron but mikasa idly brushes off
the question their conversation is
halted when yelena arrives and
subsequently surprises everyone by
shooting greece for insulting the
aldians as yelena explains zeke's true
motives armin begins to cry claiming he
is moved by yelena's noble intentions
before a soldier arrives to inform them
about the infiltrators the survey corps
members and other prisoners are
subsequently alerted by the rattling of
the walls and arm and remarks that the
titans have started moving several
minutes later onyakubun arrives and
unlocks the cell door asking they help
aaron as connie slams him against the
wall armin tells connie to let him go
and hear his side before doing anything
after ian kapoor continues to plead his
innocence and that he did not desire to
eradicate the elden race armand recalls
the time when they converse about how
someone thought it would be interesting
to have different kinds of people in the
world which includes eldians helping him
to his feet armin asks mikasa if she
wants to help aaron after getting a
reluctant response armand mentions how
he believes what aaron said to him was
nothing more than just a lie to make
yelana and zeke believe he was on their
side he continues on by stating that
when the rumbling is activated the other
nations will be observing from marley
and see that the few hundred titans
within the walls awaken will prevent
them from attacking parody island after
the other captured soldiers are released
armin goes to suit up with mikasa as
mikasa continues to believe what eren
said about her to be true armin brushes
her concerns aside and states that aaron
used the excuse about her headaches to
make the lie more believable as they
reach the roof they spot yelena staring
up at the destruction overhead as yelena
mentions how zeke was able to defeat
both hanji and levi armin continues to
play along and rallies the others to
join the jaegerists and saving both
aaron and zeke in order to save the
world armin then turns around to see
yelena peering down at him intensely and
then asks for them to save aaron as the
survey court tries to get close to aaron
armin and the others notice zeke getting
shot atop the wall and falling back down
to the ground as armin decides him and
mikasa need to target the kart titan
they both get shot at by several marlin
soldiers after connie launches a
thunderspear and saves them armin
overhears commander pixis and niall dock
organizing the ground soldiers he agrees
with the plan and has mikasa go with him
to get behind the enemy as they travel
through the air armin and other survey
corps soldiers hear zeke scream and
notice several flashes of light
throughout shiganshina district they
realize that the affected soldiers have
been turned into titans and their task
will now be even harder reaching the
kart titan armin fires a thunderspear at
it and destroys the artillery cannon as
peak and the soldiers try to kill armin
mikasa swiftly kills the two soldiers
armin then angles around peak as mikasa
aims to strike the car titan as they are
fighting armin and mikasa are caught off
guard as walmaria begins to crumble and
are horrified to see the titans inside
emerging as the wall titans begin to
march armin assumes that aaron is using
the founding titan to send the wall
titans to attack the forces amassing in
marley to attack parody however he's
perplexed to see that all of wall maria
is crumbling noting that an attack on
marley should have only required the
titans contained in shiganshina's outer
wall he is interrupted by aaron who
begins speaking to all subjects of ymir
through the founding titan to armin's
horror aaron declares that he's going to
be using the founding titan to
completely exterminate all life outside
parody island arm and mikasa regroup
with jean and connie who have falco with
them although jean half-heartedly tries
to justify aaron's plan armin is firmly
opposed to the genocide that aaron is
about to commit noticing their fellow
soldiers being attacked by titans armin
and jean go to help them but mikasa
points out that they need to deal with
falco jean suggests feeding the boy to
one of the titans while connie argues
that his mother should be allowed to eat
falco armin does not want to sacrifice
falco at all arguing that killing him
will only breed more animosity with the
warriors but connie angrily points out
that armin is being a hypocrite for not
allowing his mother to be saved the way
armin himself was saved the group is
attacked by a titan allowing connie to
flee with falco before the group can
stop him the group returns to the
military headquarters where they rally
the soldiers trapped inside to help them
kill the titans which have amassed
around the building after clearing out
the first wave of titans armin's group
lies in wait at the building while more
soldiers lead the remaining titans to
the building to be killed armin
recognizes one of the titans to be pixes
and quickly mourns the commander before
executing him after the fighting mr
blaus brings armin and mikasa to meet
gabby who begs him to return falco to
her armin explains what has happened to
falco and gabby desperately tries to
argue that aaron can return connie's
mother to normal with the founding titan
but armin points out that aaron would
likely have used such an ability on the
titans in shinganshina if he could gabby
frantically argues that aaron should be
able to as he was able to undo the armor
titan's hardening abilities hearing this
armin recalls aaron's proclamation that
he has undone all hardening and realizes
that annie's crystal must have also been
affected armin decides to depart for
ragako with gabby to try to catch connie
mikasa tries to convince him that it is
futile but armin is determined to at
least try to preserve any chance of
making peace with the warriors mikasa
attempts to ask what they should do
about aaron causing armin to lash out at
her immediately regretting his actions
armin laments that he was the one saved
in shiganshina not irwin as erwin would
have been able to handle the current
situation armin departs for ragako with
gabby soon after armin and gabby arrive
at ragako as connie is preparing to feed
falco to his mother when armin fails to
talk connie down he reflects once again
that irwin should have lived instead of
him and chooses to sacrifice himself to
save connie's mother however he is saved
from being devoured by connie who
explains that he has come to realize
that his mother would not want someone
else to be sacrificed for her after
returning to shiganshina the group takes
time to rest and eat as they are eating
armin and connie discuss the possibility
of annie having escaped her crystal as
they are speaking they realize that
annie is sitting next to them after
receiving a signal from jean to leave
the military headquarters armin departs
with his comrades on their way out of
shiganshina they pick up reiner the
group camps out together and attempt to
learn aaron's location from yelana
things go sour when yelana instead
begins trying to turn the group against
each other by reminding them of each
other's crimes armin's attack on
liberio's port using his colossus titan
being one of them she eventually gets
jon to attack reiner for causing marco's
death forcing armin and connie to
separate the two the group travels to
paradise harbor with the intention of
using the azumabito clan's airship to
pursue aaron but find that it is already
occupied by jaegerists the group gears
up for a possible engagement but armin
and his friends are reluctant to fight
their former comrades their discussion
is interrupted by hanji who announces to
everyone's horror that aaron has
apparently already reached marley a
desperate magath apologizes to the
aldians for how he and the rest of
barley treated them and begs them to
cooperate with him as part of a plan to
trick flock into turning over the
azumabito mechanics armin and connie
ride into the harbor and tell flock that
they have been pursuing the car titan
ever since it devoured jean and ayakopon
they tell flock to send the azumobito
mechanics to help them start the ship so
they can continue their pursuit and
proceed to the ship without waiting for
his response they are stopped by daz and
samuel and seeing that the plane has
been rigged to explode demand that they
disarm it daz and samuel questioned them
about their allegiance and armin and
connie managed to convince them to begin
disarming the bombs on the plane as they
are waiting for the mechanics armin and
connie are horrified to hear gunshots
followed by an announcement from flock
that they and mikasa are traitors daz
begins rewiring the bombs on the plane
and armin tries to stop him only to get
shot in three places by samuel as connie
wrestles with samuel armin continues to
try to stop daz despite his injuries daz
tries to shoot him forcing connie to
kill daz and samuel to save armin armin
stretches out his arm trying to grab
dazz but to no avail as his corpse sinks
in the ocean armin then stares at a
distraught connie with tears in his eyes
while samuel's corpse lays on the floor
with three bullet holes whilst the fight
is going on connie carries armin up to
magoth who deduces that his wounds will
heal soon enough connie goes to help the
others waltz magath carries armin aboard
the boat after his injuries have healed
armin goes to the deck of the boat where
he's suddenly taken into paths by aaron
aaron reveals to armin his attack
titan's power to see memories of the
future and that all of his cruel actions
in the past days were committed with the
desire to distance himself from his
friends in preparation for the atrocity
he was about to commit he attempts to
apologize for beating armin but armin
insists that he should be apologizing to
mikasa for the things that he said to
her armin asks if aaron's intentions
were to set up his friends as the world
saviors which aaron confirms the world
now owes a debt to armin and his friends
for saving it from imminent destruction
armin points out that the outside world
might still retaliate but aaron reveals
that his rumbling has wiped out 80
percent of the world's population
meaning all four nations will be unable
to retaliate for the foreseeable future
armin is horrified and asks if aaron's
actions were necessary but aaron ignores
him and instead asks that armin follow
him to another place aaron takes armand
to an erupting volcano to show him the
liquid fire that he had read about as a
child lava the two discussed yamir fritz
and aaron reveals to armin's surprise
that the reason ymir remained servile to
king fritz even centuries after his
death was because she truly loved him
the two proceed onwards to a new
location a snowy landscape
where aaron continues explaining yamir's
mindset armin is shocked to learn from
aaron that ymir was seemingly freed from
her millennial long servitude by mikasa
eric reflects that every atrocious act
he committed was unknowingly done in the
service of freeing ymir and armin
acknowledges the pain that his friend
must have been in to shoulder such a
burden on his own aaron begins
confessing more but armin cuts him off
to spare him the pain the two go to the
ocean and armin asks aaron if he
believes mikasa can move on from him
aaron claims he does not know causing
armin to punch him in the face for
pushing her away armin ridicules aaron
suggesting that mikasa will forget about
him quickly causing aaron to break down
and admit that he doesn't want mikasa to
move on armin tries to convince aaron
that they will find a way to keep him
alive but aaron refuses to entertain the
idea reminding armin that he will never
be forgiven for what he's done the ocean
scene before them transforms into a
ruined landscape of trampled land and
bodies and aaron admits to armin that he
would have kept rumbling even if his
friends had not tried to stop him armin
demands to know why but aaron claims he
does not know as aaron prepares to erase
armin's memories temporarily promising
that they will return after his dies
armin finds a seashell on the ground
giving the seashell to his old friend
armin thanks him for everything he has
done for paradise's sake the two embrace
and armin is once again standing on the
deck of the boat with no memory of his
and aaron's conversation annie calls him
over to sit with her and thanks him for
talking to her while she was stuck in
her crystal but asks why he chose to
talk to her and not anyone else armin
tries to tell annie how he feels about
her but annie chooses to instead believe
that he only talked to her because he's
a good person armin reminds her that he
does not like being called a good person
noting that he has killed many people
and chosen to portray his own race armin
laments that the world beyond the walls
did not match his and aaron's dream but
he tells annie that he still chooses to
believe that there is a part of the
world yet to be discovered after
arriving in odiha armin helps move the
flying boat into a hangar to be worked
on his comrades try to remove the
explosives on the boat but armin
suggests leaving them in case they are
needed later after helping the mechanics
for a time armin returns to the boat to
find levi attempting to walk he tries to
convince levi to continue resting but
levi insists that they need to
interrogate yelana as preparations for
the flying boat near completion armen
bids goodbye to annie who has decided to
stay behind before the group can depart
however flock reveals himself and shoots
holes in the boat's fuel tank
necessitating repairs as repairs begin
though aaron's titans arrive in odiha
armin volunteers to stay behind to hold
them off but reiner insists that the
colossus titan will be needed to stop
aaron hanji decides to stay and hold the
titans off and names armin as the 15th
commander of the survey corps armin and
the others managed to get the boat
running before the titans reach the
hangar all on board are left heartbroken
by hanji's death based on levi and
peak's descriptions of aaron's titan and
the knowledge that warhammer inheritors
can remotely control their titans armin
and pique agree that the best plan would
be for him to use his colossus titans
transformation to destroy aaron's titan
in one attack although armin still
insists on trying to talk aaron down
first prompted by reiner armin reminds
the group that aaron has not restricted
them from using their titan powers even
though he has the ability to do so and
suggests that aaron might be trying to
go them into stopping him the
conversation is interrupted when the
group is abruptly pulled into paths
armin immediately tries to negotiate
with aaron arguing that his actions will
dissuade anyone from harming parody for
centuries to come he hears aaron's voice
telling him that the rumbling will not
stop before seeing a child like aaron in
the distance armin mikasa john and
connie tried to reach him but they're
unable to get any closer armin tries to
get aaron to speak with them but aaron
tells him that he only called them to
paths to tell them that they will have
to kill him to stop the rumbling as the
flying boat reaches aaron armin tries to
get on yakupunt to abandon the flying
boat with the rest of the group but
onyakapon insists on staying with the
boat to get it as close to aaron as
possible as the boat gets closer it
comes under fire from the beast titan
and armin and his friends are forced to
abandon the boat in the middle of the
barrage using their maneuvering gear the
group avoids the beast's projectiles and
begin engaging it they make short work
of the beast titan but find that zeke is
not inside its nape at john's prompting
armin orders his comrades to evacuate
the area so that he can transform and
use the blast to try to uncover zeke's
location as he prepares to transform
armin recalls his former conviction that
leaders must be willing to make
sacrifices and begrudgingly admits that
he might need to kill aaron however
before he can transform armin is
attacked from behind by a titan as the
titan begins to swallow him whole armin
is surprised by the sight of ymir fritz
nearby watching him inside the titan's
mouth armin begins to suffocate he
concludes that ymir is the one
generating titans to defend aaron and
begins to lament that he and his
comrades are powerless to stop the two
of them as he begins to pass out armin
seesburgh told hoover standing before
him armin stares down at his unconscious
body and grows frustrated that it will
not move as he remembers his friends he
begins insulting himself lamenting that
all he ever does is let himself and
others down as he angrily proclaims that
he has wasted the second chance at life
he was given armin realizes that he is
surrounded by sand seeing the sand armin
realizes that the fact that he can still
see and think means he is still getting
oxygen to his brain and is still alive
realizing he is in the paths again armin
realizes that he might be able to
continue helping his friends through the
connections all eldians have in paths
his thinking is almost immediately
derailed though when he sees zeke yeager
sitting nearby he introduces himself to
zeke and zeke asks armin if ymir has
consumed him armin sits with zeke and
listens as zeke explains his theory
about the origin of life zeke theorizes
that all life forms find their meaning
by multiplying and that it was a result
in fear of death which caused yamir to
spawn her undying titan body and escape
to the world of the path zeke theorizes
that the reason she continued to obey
the fritz family for two thousand years
was because she still felt a connection
to the world and that she likely chose
to help aaron because he was the first
person able to understand her armin
tries to get zeke to tell him how to
escape the pathworld but zeke believes
there's no point in continuing to fight
armin reminds the man that their allies
are fighting for the lives of innocent
people but zeke points out that every
living thing must die eventually seeing
a leaf stuck in the soil armin recalls a
time in his youth when he raced aaron
and mikasa to the top of a hill outside
shiganchina recounting the memory to
zeke armin claims that in that moment he
had felt that the only reason he had
been born was to try to race his friends
he had felt that same way reading as a
child feeding small animals and shopping
with his friends showing zeke the leaf
from the soil armin claims that even
though he does not need it to live it is
still precious to him he hands zeke the
leaf and is shocked to see the human
forms of many past titan inheritors
standing behind him as zeke wakes up the
inheritors armin notices ymir fritz was
watching them from the distance before
turning to see berthold acknowledging
his role in bertolt's death armin asks
his former ally to help him armin is
saved from the titan which kidnapped him
by mikasa who slices its mouth open the
titan manages to impale his leg with its
tongue and armin uses a thunderspear to
kill it but he begins to get dragged
down with its carcass connie cuts him
free and annie catches him armin
explains to his friends that zeke was
able to use the connection all eldians
have to awaken the consciousness of some
of the former nine titans their new
allies are able to give them the opening
necessary to detonate the explosives on
aaron's nape reiner keeps the centipede
in aaron's nape from reattaching and the
rest of the group flees atop falco
grice's flying jaw titan clearing the
area as armin prepares to transform
thanking the nine titans who help them
armin bids goodbye to aaron and
transforms emerging from the crater
where he transformed armin follows
reiner towards fort salta seeking to
destroy the source of all living matter
shortly after another massive explosion
rocks the planes and aaron now
controlling the body of a colossus titan
emerges from the clouds of steam armin
turns around to face him when the source
of all living matter suddenly emits a
cloud of gas armin continues his pace
towards aaron leaving reiner to deal
with the source ignoring the sudden
horde of titans armin attempts to
grapple aaron declaring that he will
fight him until the very end although he
lands a hit against aaron's head he is
swiftly disadvantaged when aaron lands a
devastating blow against his own head
despite the melee combat he hears
mikasa's oath to finish aaron off
assisting by holding aaron's head in
place to allow levi to fire a
thunderspear towards it receiving
another crushing blow from aaron that
caves in the left side of his titan's
head armin's assistance pays off as
mikasa is able to enter the mouth of
aaron's titan and swiftly sever his
exposed human head armin awakes on the
ground outside of his disintegrating
titan his memories of his and aaron's
final conversation restored as he gets
his bearings mikasa approaches him and
armin is heartbroken to see that she is
carrying aaron's decapitated head as
armin weeps for his friend mikasa asks
if he remembers aaron coming to visit
him now and armin confirms that he does
remember mikasa's choice to kill aaron
has destroyed the power of the titans
after armin has mourned his friend
mikasa tells him that she is leaving to
give aaron a proper burial the two
agreed that the best place would be
under the tree he used to nap under when
he was a child and mikasa departs armin
returns to the rest of the aliens to
find them being held at gunpoint by
secretary muller and his forces mueller
demands that the eldians prove that they
can no longer turn into titans or face
immediate execution and armin steps
forward in his people's defense he
points out to the marlins that if they
still possess the ability to turn into
titans they would be using that very
ability to defend themselves the fact
that they are at the marlins mercy must
logically mean they no longer possess
the power of the titans muller orders
his men to lower their firearms and asks
for armin's name armin introduces
himself as the man who killed aaron
jaeger in the three years following the
battle of heaven and earth at fort salta
armin and the other survivors are
appointed as diplomats to facilitate
peace talks between the outside world
and parody as they are sailing to parody
to begin the talks the group reads a
letter from historia explaining the
current state of paradise's government
the ambassadors are all skeptical of
their mission but armin is convinced
that the people of parody will be
willing to listen to reason when they
see the warriors and the survey corps
former enemies working together for a
common cause
thank you so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us we'll
see you guys very soon in one of our
next videos